ladies and gentlemen welcome to the Tim
Dylan show very special episode uh we're
joined Again by Noah tishby uh who is
here no I'm kidding it's Freaky Friday
and we have journalist Abby Martin here
with us as we promised we would get um
her documentary Gaza fights for Freedom
which I watched again the other night
and a lot of people are now
rediscovering the documentary because
they're uneducated about what's going on
as I am um and you have been boots on
the ground covering this issue for years
when no one cared about it um and your
concern and what's interesting about you
you're you're a big critic of Israel we
know that but I don't really hear a lot
of people calling you anti-semitic I
don't see that I don't I've never heard
you like engage in any kind of weird
conspiracy mongering about the Jewish
question or whatever you you focus on
facts and you report facts that are
uncomfortable to governments this is
what I've always seen right whether it's
the American government or the Israeli
government that's what you do and you
don't you're you go to these places you
have you spent time in Gaza um so what
is from someone who has sources there
who speaks to people there who knows
people there what is happening right now
because I think uh a lot of people
obviously recognize hamas's attack was
brutal and everybody is you know has
sympathy for people whose children are
being hostages or whose family is being
hostages um but there are also a lot of
civilians in Gaza that are dying and
you've covered that closer than probably
anyone I know what is going on there
now I I'm glad that you set up that
pretext because I am a journalist
critical of us Empire and its proxy
forces and Israel is its Central proxy
in the Middle East and there's a
multitude of reasons for that can we
move your mic just a little closer
because yeah perfect so there's a
multitude of reasons geopolitical
reasons why the US supports and backs
Israel so much I as a media critic and
as a propaganda critic my whole life I I
realized Israeli propaganda echoed by
the US was such an important case study
and so I really have done a deep dive
over the last 10 years speaking to
hundreds of Palestinians speaking to
dozens of Israelis including former
soldiers going there on the ground
spending a month in the occupied West
Bank I'm actually banned for life from
entering Gaza I was told that I was a
propagandist and an Iranian agent from
the Israeli government I thought that I
was a Venezuelan agent and a Russian
agent so I can't keep up you wear a lot
of hats I wear a lot of hats um so I
wasn't actually able to get in but I
worked with journalists inside through
the blockade to create Gaza fights for
Freedom what is going on right now is a
textbook case of genocide and I can
explain why this isn't just me
pontificating from an armchair analysis
the these are Holocaust
Scholars um three of which have actually
put forward a case against Anthony
blinkin and Joe Biden for complicity in
genocide they have actually set formal
charges um these are Holocaust Scholars
that are Israeli historians asserting
this so not only that but of course you
have the crime of apartheid these are
the most serious crimes against humanity
so I could talk about context all day
long I could about talk about context
behind the October 7th attack but all of
that is kind of pushed to the side when
you see what is Israel doing in response
right now and that is committing
genocide against the palestin the the I
guess the response that they would say
is that if they wanted to do a genocide
they would have done it already they
they're basically saying their argument
is we're responding to this attack we're
trying to get rid of Hamas and our
mission is to uh you know eradicate the
leadership of Hamas and Hamas Fighters
and they embed themselves with civilians
this is this is what is out there as the
party line and this is what is being
said I'm sure there some you know
there's there's elements of Truth to
everything right so they're they're
basically saying
hamas's uh you know uh command centers
are all under hospitals I don't know if
this is obviously you're familiar with
that and is this something that is well
known is this true in your
estimation so okay they say that they
are targeting Hamas right right now
during the 4-day truce we've seen
kind of the death toll like be accounted
for at this moment now that the
hospitals that have been bombed
relentlessly are able to finally account
for the dead 20,000 civilians have been
killed I'm sorry 20,000 people have been
killed they claim a thousand were
Fighters so right out of the gate that's
an extraordinary amount of civilians 70%
women and children yeah 8,000 children
8,000 children you have un officials you
have like um people who have documented
War zones all over the world saying this
is unprecedented
this is an unprecedented amount of
Carnage it's a blood bath and it's a
Slaughter housee and they have never
seen anything like it so for Israel to
claim that they are targeting Hamas it
doesn't really make sense when you look
at the complete destruction and leveling
of Civilian areas they are targeting
hospitals they are targeting Schools
they're targeting mosques where they
know tons of civilians are Sheltering
there Hamas is underground so why would
you level the entirety of the
infrastructure on top Gaza if you're
trying to Target Fighters underground
and no there is absolutely no evidence
for human Shields and I can debunk that
all day and there's no evidence for
command centers under
hospitals interesting and is this
something that because Bill Clinton has
repeated like a lot of people have
repeated that idea that the command
centers are under the
hospitals um early on in this conflict
there was a hospital I I'm forgetting
the name here Arab the one that they
claimed was a errant missile right right
was they claimed that it was an errant
missile from Hamas but a lot of people
thought that it was potentially a strike
a missile strike where are you on that
so there's so there's so many lies I
mean Israeli propaganda it it's very
well funded there's a billion dollar
apparatus behind this there's war rooms
at telev University that fund and employ
people to like correct the record online
it's very it's a very concerted effort
to aisc the obvious reality so right out
of the gate on October 7th almost all of
the lies um all of the things that we
were told turn out to be lies beheaded
babies the mass rape all of those things
it turned out to be a lot of that was
false we actually don't know exactly
what happened on October 7th because
everything Israel said has turned out to
be lies then it turned to what was
happening in Gaza human Shields um and
then the most egregious attack at first
was the Ali Arab Hospital 500 civilians
were massacred in this bombing it was
completely shocking because it was the
largest casualty mass casualty event
ever against Palestinians from Israel so
that was like really shocking there was
a lot of international outrage that was
mounting and then immediately all of the
sudden the news became actually was an
errant missile from Islamic Jihad now I
I immediately just stepped back and
thought wow that's so crazy that an
errant rocket the first time in the
history of this conflict was able to
kill 500 people if that's the Manpower
of these Rockets we would have seen a
lot more civilians dead cuz Rockets do
miss fire sure in the strip sure um that
is unprecedented level of Carnage and so
um this is this is how you know it's
false Tim you don't need to know
anything else about the blast radius or
the zone or what it looked like
afterward none of that matters or even
the satellite footage of of that
actually turned out to be debunk they
reversed the angle of it this is how you
know it's a lie Israel released doctored
audio recordings after claiming to be
Islam IC Jihad operatives talking to
each other proving that they had the
command center or that they had misfired
the rocket excuse me I'm talking about
another propaganda thing later on about
the alifa hospital so they actually
released an audio recording of two
Islamic Jihad operatives being like hey
man that was my rocket oh man like we
[__] up we shot it was crazy and then
what turned out and how do we know
they're doctor because audio forensics
experts from Channel 4 News yeah which
is a mainstream news publication they
analyzed the and found out that they're
recording on two separate channels like
you would like a podcast and then mix
them together it wasn't a a legitimate
phone call and plus people in Gaza don't
use just cell phones they know
everything's recorded and monitored
through surveillance so they use
different kinds of methods to to discuss
things and so the fact that that was a
doctored recording really just pokes a
hole in the whole narrative why if it
was embarrassing first it was an a
missile why the hell would you relase it
and then I found out Tim this is insane
all of my um all of this comes back to
2010 the flotilla Massacre when Israeli
forces common deer to ship in
international waters and executed like
eight or nine activists on board
completely unarmed that were just
delivering Aid to Gaza that's when I
woke up to how egregious the propaganda
was because I saw our mainstream media
Running With The Narrative that people
on the boat were the ones who were
aggressors trying to Stave off Commandos
that had just executed their friends
with tables and chairs and acting like
they deserve to be executed back then
Israeli forces released an audio
recording doctored claiming that the
people on the ship were saying go back
to asts that turned out later to be
false they admitted as such this is a
Playbook that I'm realizing that they do
yeah well it's interesting the Israeli
lob like John mimer who's a historian
wrote a book about the Israeli Lobby and
he described it as this kind of loose
Coalition of interest groups not all of
them Jewish a lot of them are Christians
right A lot of them are like
fundamentalist Christians in America
that are deeply supportive of all of
Israel's actions right um and uh you
know obviously certain interest groups
have a lot of power and and and have a
lot of influence and that's certainly
one of them um and you know what he had
said recently he was on Lex freedman's
podcast he said the definition of
anti-semitism is now expanded to include
any criticism of Israel so if you
criticize Israel's actions it's
anti-semitic but he goes a lot of the
policies being pushed by hardliners in
Israel aren't good for Israelis and
they're not good for Americans you know
a lot of I didn't think the Iraq War was
great for Americans right I mean all of
these things that we now know we look
back on these you know Foreign Wars and
how much money we've spent we've sent uh
floods of refugees all over the world
and we see these are not policies that
have been good for Americans right they
they enriched a small percentage of
Americans you know um how do you how do
you separate there is clearly
anti-Semitism there are people that hate
you there are people that think they
control the whole world there are people
that think that they're in the cupboard
they're everywhere they're under the bed
whatever it is how do you separate that
because there are some of those people
out there and some of them are going to
these marches and some of them are you
know probably uh you know uh you know
there certainly there are crazy things
going on at colleges people being locked
in libraries people being harassed how
do you separate that which is a real
issue from
the kind of legitimate criticism of the
actions of Israel and let's not forget
the Risen anti-palestinian hate as well
three people just got shot just got shot
100% two of them might die because they
were wearing
C horrible and I there was a young child
that was shot too young child stabbed to
death so there is people that are given
any excuse to hate will hate and do
horrible things you know and
anti-Semitism is I I think it is on the
rise worldwide for just in general and
it has been well before October 7th I
think islamophobia has been on the rise
in general well before October 7th so
these are huge problems yeah the problem
is that Israel conflates itself with a
peaceful beautiful religion right right
it it claims to represent the land of
the Jewish people and it slaps the Star
of David on a colonizing Force it's a
colonizing apartheid settler colonial
state now explain that because their
argument is a lot of lands including the
one we're on right now America are have
been founded through plunder and and and
and thievery to a degree right this is a
lot of the world we look at the world in
the way these countries came into being
right right what makes uh Israel
different because they're they the
contention out there is like saying that
Jewish people shouldn't have a Homeland
uh when no one says that about America
or you know other countries for example
they they are they say that that in in
of itself is a anti-Semitism and it's
it's it's about the eradication of the
Jewish people right so first of all um
you mentioned earlier that you know
anti-Semitism in general I think that
this is being debunked this was
basically the excuse to Tamp down on any
criticism of Israel for a long long time
and a lot of the times it worked because
you're putting people on the defense who
are anti-racist and anti- bigot and
saying you're anti-semitic for
criticizing this state and so a lot of
people were just reflexively like no no
no okay and that's why you have this
tendency of liberals to just kind of
like apologize and excuse what's been
going on for a long time until Jewish
people became a an important facet of
the pro Palestine solidarity movement
and I think that we've seen an enormous
wave of Jewish solidarity activists
staging direct actions participating in
these protests right it's insane I mean
you can no longer say
that that it's anti-semitic to criticize
Israel when you see such a huge
component be Jewish people themselves
religious and secular second of all um
when people say do you think that Israel
has the right to exist it's not so much
about do Jews have the right to exist in
a in in a place like obviously they do
here's here's the question when you say
does Israel have the right to exist what
are we talking about here are you
talking about does Israel have the right
to exist as an apartheid state does
Israel have the right to exist as a
military occupation and does Israel have
the right to exist as a colonizing
entity where you are subjugating another
people and brutalizing them in a cruel
fashion no right so now this a partide
state yes explain that yeah to to people
I I will and and to your point also
about we are sitting on a land that was
you know we ethnically Cleanse This Land
of Native Americans horrible genocide
that took place we all acknowledge how
horrible the genocide was hundreds of
years ago right it's awful if that were
happening right now I would not support
it right that Israel for 75 years has
been based on like Noah tishby you know
what was really insulting to me about
her being on the show is that she lied
she didn't share the clip she lied to
you and lied to your audience yeah look
Israel you can criticize the policies of
Israel but the problem is the policies
that you're criticizing are foundational
to the state it is foundational to have
a military occupation that is that is
what Israel exists upon is is an
apartheid state where they subjugate and
have different laws for the Palestinian
residents what would be the other
way um you know obviously we don't we
don't want like the situation in Gaza is
terrible right I mean the the the people
living under those conditions this is
not good um what would be the way to do
it is it a two-state solution where each
state has an autonomous thing how does
it work so yeah because it seems like I
don't feel like they're all going to
live together happily that's just my
inct certainly not at first I mean this
is no one's going to hold hands together
and you know and sing I mean this is
something that's going to take decades
yeah just like just I mean just like
farc in Colombia like these things
happen and they happen with a lot of
international oversight right and
parameters set up where people have to
abide by the rules of you know
coexistence um the bloody violent
Conquest that Israel is based upon and
the expansionist nature that Israel is
based upon is a huge problem right if if
Israel just was created in 1948 with
1948 borders and then chilled and
chilled out it's a different story it
would be a different story settlements
the evicting people from home this is a
completely different story insane look
at just from October 7th in the West
Bank where Hamas doesn't have any ruling
Authority 200 people have been killed
just last night four teenage boys were
executed by Israeli snipers and left to
bleed out because they started blocking
the ambulances from getting to their
bodies during the truce if that happened
if Hamas killed four Israeli teenagers
last night what do you think the news
would be right now so when I look at
what is the solution what does Israel
have the right to exist as the majority
of the Arabs in Palestine have agreed
upon a two-state solution with 1967
borders Israel has rejected that for the
last 20 years there is no room in with
the
1990s deal that almost happened well
Israel has rejected Palestine papers
came out about a decade or so ago and
they show show secret negotiations no if
you look at the secret negotiations
between Israel and Palestine over the
last you know from from the 1990s until
2010 every single concession that
Palestinian leaders made Israel rejected
and laughed out of the room they even
offered to be permanently
demilitarized they offered Jerusalem
they offered I mean they offered almost
everything imaginable because Israel
doesn't want Palestinians to have a
state right and and so today the center
of gravity in Israel shifted to the
right 100% And and there was a time
every American president again this is
right out of M shimer on fredman which I
think is was is is well worth a listen
um every American president was saying
we need a Palestinian State we need two
states from when I was a kid but that
idea has seemed to have gone out the
window there doesn't seem to be the
political will for it uh in the last 10
20 years I haven't heard it much and
Israel seems to not care about it as
much it's just Americans who are plated
in this idea of a fantasy of inevitable
peace through this two-state solution
diplomatic process that is false it's a
false hope right and it's really
insulting because it's dangled in front
of American audiences we're the ones who
are propaganda to Israeli Society knows
exactly what's going on they're not
committed to it they're not committed to
that's been a dead notion for the last
25 years in Israel like no one talks
about this at all um it's Americans who
who they want to propagandize to us
that's why you have Israeli authorities
all the time going on American Media
speaking English to us that's why you
have us officials lying to our faces
about what is going on while Israeli
politicians are openly inciting the fact
that they have genocidal aspirations for
Gaza that they want take over raise Gaza
to the ground and colonize it recolonize
is
Hamas uh
a they are the governing body of Gaza I
guess de facto right like they were
elected they get a lot of money from
Qatar they're funded by Qatar they get
hundreds of millions of dollars
um what what is the mission statement of
a Hamas what do they want out of what's
what they're doing what was what was the
hope of what they did on October 7th is
it a pgam is it to kill Jewish people is
it to it doesn't seem like Hamas is
interested in having Israel be there at
all would that be fair to say or are
they is their AV
verion I mean when we look at Hamas is
this a do they have the best interest of
Palestinians at heart
I think you have to look at this is
where the context does come into play
because Hamas only you know Hamas hasn't
been around for that long and when they
were elected they were the ones who
pushed Israeli colonizers out of Gaza in
2005 so you have to look at the context
of that election which was the first and
only election in the Gaza Strip yeah um
and half the people that live there
today weren't around when when got
elected lot of young people yeah a lot
of children half children um and so that
that's the context of why they were
elected and they do provide a lot of
services you know for for Gaza residents
they're I think it's really cartoonish
to
debase them and say they're a terrorist
group who hates Jews and their objective
is to wipe Jews not only off the map in
Israel but off the world's map like
that's what I hear politicians saying
all the time does Hamas not say that
though so their initial Charter did have
anti-semitic language right and I think
you have to look at when you're being
colonized is it really a deep-seated
hatred of Jewish people or is it that
you the only Jewish people you know are
the ones brutalizing and killing you and
your family so when people slap a star
of David on their uniform and they're
brutalizing and killing and occupying
you those are the only Jews you know is
there anti-Semitism within Hamas
probably is there anti-Semitism among
Palestinians in Gaza probably and that's
really unfortunate because they don't
know any other Jewish people but I think
Hamas has a very money from Qatar they
get hundreds of millions of dollars the
leaders of Hamas live in these pretty
lavish uh you know condos of the Four
Seasons in Qatar how is is any of that
money being used to help the lives of
civilians in Gaza well I want to finish
the point before but what do you think
the objective was on October 7th I think
that we've seen it with the hostage
exchange and the Prisoner exchange that
just happened the first round of it is
that there they were trying to gain
leverage yeah and when they shoot
Rockets they don't wake up one day and
say huh how many Jews can we kill today
with indiscriminate rocket fire no it's
usually in response to something heinous
that's being done for sure like the
alaxa raid where you had a hundred
Rodney King beatings happening
simultaneously of worshippers during
Ramadan that shit's crazy dude no you
have these these
these you have examples of Israeli
aggression um you also have Palestinian
terrorist attacks um it doesn't seem
like obviously Israel is a superior
military right so they had to know that
Israel was going to
respond October 7th they had to know
they were going to do well Tim as you
know what what does Israel do when they
don't do anything I mean you saw the
documentary right I mean tens of
thousands of people peacefully marched
to the artificial border fence and they
were mowed down by sniper fire right I
mean this is what happens when
Palestinians do anything peacefully or
not guess the Israeli contention would
be that those Palestinians are not would
not be living in Israel peacefully they
would just be there would be because
hamasa said we're just going to do
October 7th again and again and again so
like that's kind of that issue where I
completely understand the the the
defense the Gaza thing [__] up I think
a lot of Israelis are probably going if
these borders open up and people come
here is it is are we going to just see
what we just saw okay so I you you
mentioned what does Hamas want their new
Charter that was revised over a decade
ago talks about the differentiation
between political Zionism and Judaism
first and foremost and it also talks
about the acceptance of a two-state
solution among 1967 borders so even
Hamas is willing to accept Israel as a
Jewish state if Palestinians had their
own State no one talks about this um I'm
not sure about the comment that you're
saying about we do October 7th again
again the thing is but the thing is I
think that the goal is to have rights
it's like they are saying we're not
going to stop trying to gain leverage
and trying to gain something well yeah
there's contacts for it like slavo xak
you know made a great point he goes
listen it's a horrific attack I'm I'm
obviously not going to condone an attack
but we we can't remove the context of
what uh you know has motivated the
attack and it's not solely the hatred of
Jews right it's it's that there's this
situation that the people in that area
have lived under that uh is
unsustainable and creates people that
are hopeless and willing to embrace
these crazy methods right um I think if
you were to say yeah I mean this is I
don't know we will repeat October 7th
again and again a Hamas official I don't
know yeah until probably until they so
then Israel have international rights
that are recognized and not under
internationally illegally recognized
blockade that has tightened um every
year and this would this would involve
Israel kind of giving up the settlements
they have to that that's why all these
settlements are deemed illegal on
international law because since' 67 they
have further encroached and encroached
and encroached and and just since
October 7th 16 over 16 Villages have
been like ethnically cleansed at the
barrel of a gun you have Ben gavier one
of the Ministers of the Israeli
government going out and handing out
machine guns to the settlers just saying
like let's get this done while all eyes
are are on Gaza let's let's go let's go
let's ramp up the ethnic cleansing in
the West Bank and that really shows you
that that exposes what Israel is all
about right I mean this this is what it
is it's not about eliminating Hamas it's
not about eliminating Hamas they it it's
so explicit and it's so laid bare right
um and that's what's so offensive about
it it's like
look you they have to have rights you
cannot treat people this way this is
this is the definition of blowback right
this is what happens when you subjugate
people under the rule and control of one
body and I want to just provide like
this thought experiment it's like the
fact that they keep saying it's a war
it's a war between Israel and Hamas what
kind of war is waged against a a cage
population how do you bomb people and
say oh just leave they have nowhere to
[__] go how do you do that yeah it it
is wild the idea of like I guess their
their contention would be there are
other countries that could take them out
they control Egypt they tell Egypt when
to jump and how high who Israel yes 100%
they' bragged about it look there's
articles everywhere about Israeli
officials bragging about how much Egypt
does what they say right but what's even
crazier is like how could you go at war
against an entity that you occupy and
control every facet of their lives
that's not a war that's crazy right
that's crazy and this absolutely the
just the fact just the notion that you
can cut off electricity food Aid and
fuel how I mean doesn't that prove right
there that they're have a complete
control over what enters Gaza I guess
they would say Rockets come in weapons
come in things like that come in and
they would say how is it an open air
prison if Hamas is able to maintain uh
you know a steady stream of rockets and
materials things like that well they
build the tunnels that because they also
want things like fast food I mean
there's things that tunnels are used for
that's not just Rockets but I it it look
The Siege is a criminal Endeavor um they
even put Palestinians on a diet they
they've figured out the minimum caloric
intake to just be right above
malnutrition I mean it's it's sick and
it's inhumane and it needs to
stop stops these the violence is not
going to stop is the is there which
makes you know which is understandable
and it's a reality of of having this
this very combustible situation there
um is
there any is there any you know as
somebody who's looked at this issue are
there times when you look at Palestinian
actions or the actions of Hamas and say
this like do you like if Arafat in the
90s had said let's just do it like we'll
do the two-state solution would that
have helped I mean again the
Palestinians did offer every concession
it was the Israelis who said no I swear
to God yeah Palestine papers look it up
yeah I mean that's just something I mean
I don't I'm not saying you're wrong Bill
Clinton said that in his book he was
like the Palestinians are the ones who
rejected it this is a lie This Is A Lie
they tried to Israel never accepted not
taking any part of the West Bank they
always wanted a part of the West Bank
what is the West Bank why is the West
Bank so important see to me it's so
crazy to me that any piece of land would
be so important that you'd want to live
in this you know this is not good for
Israelis it's certainly not good for
Palestinians what is so important about
this land like for example if people
said to me um you know we want West
Hollywood or you could live in a
constate a war for 50 years I would go
take it you know what I mean like it's
whatever I'll I'll do something else why
is why is the why what is it about this
is it is it something else is it deeper
is it cultural is it religious what why
not just say take this West Bank I don't
know it seems crazy it's biblical
prophecy you know that it's all about
it's all about the religious is it
biblical on both sides is it also
Muslims going we don't want Jews in the
land of uh the prophet I mean that's
also kind of been said by certain people
I certainly have heard um you know
leaders say things like that or is it
you know do you think there is there's
certainly probably some biblical stuff I
mean not biblical but
religious uh stuff on that side too
perhaps I have not heard that personally
I wouldn't be surprised if there were
are people that say that I I will tell
you that out of the hundreds of
Palestinians I've talked to not one and
I am I I [__] you not not one person
told me they can't live here all of them
said we just want to live in peace
there's plenty of land why do they have
to move on top of my Village and and
terrorize me yeah just entering
Jerusalem for a couple hours I spoke to
a couple dozen Israelis just randomly on
the street and you can pull up this
video it's amazing almost every single
one was explicitly genocidal and said
kill them all wipe them off the Earth
killet bomb them and looking right at
the camera and it's like this is
shocking this is shocking I mean and and
and of course Israeli leaders too um say
the same thing you know it's not about
live in peace it's about wipe them off
the face of the Earth expel them all I
have a better cut on my phone this get
how did this
get so bad I mean I know that you know
obviously this was a you know this is
this is since
1948 um has this always been as
contentious as it is now have people
always felt this way about each other um
you know like or have have things
degenerated uh and and and was there a
time was there a time where because now
it feels like it's hopeless over there
you know it feels hopeless right it
feels like these people on both sides
don't see each other as human beings and
hate each other
and was that always the case or has this
just increased well before in historic
Palestine um Jews Christians and Arabs
did Jews Christians and Muslims all
lived in the same territory there were
mosques there were church I mean there
were synagogues all of these things were
I'm not going to say everyone was
holding hands and singing right I'm sure
that there were some problems but really
once the colonial project started that's
where you saw the resentment it's it's
about land I mean it's not yes the
greater Israel project that's why you
see commanders of the Israeli Army
saying Lebanon is ours we're going to
take Beirut we're going to turn Beirut
into God Gaza they've taken the Goan
Heights they think Sy part of Syria is
theirs lebanon's theirs it's all about
the greater Israel to a lot of these
Ultra religionist nature of it that it
will not stop yeah okay and this is this
is an issue but the Palestinians have
lived there for it's like you can talk
about ancient prophecy all day about
thousands of years ago but the reality
is who has lived there for the last
couple hundred years who has lived there
for Generations in these homes and and
and think about it like if your home if
if if [__] China came in with an
invading Army and started kicking people
out of their homes in West Hollywood
well they are doing that in Beverly
Hills but they're paying great money if
China wants to buy my H I want out of
here bad if China wants to give me five
mil I'm out but I I AG China is our only
hope in La our only hope is China coming
in and giving us money it's not
Americans they can't afford this [__] um
no and and and you know what I I fully
understand um you know cuz there listen
there's Palestinian comedians right
there's moamar there's is there's
there's people that are you know they're
they don't hate Jewish people they're
just they're you know
incredibly um disturbed by the
conditions in which Palestinians live um
and they've spoken about it passionately
and stuff like that um this this quote
from the river to the sea that has
gotten a lot of press I've never I've
never heard it up until recently but it
has been a big news story from the river
to the Sea people have said that it
means genocide of the Jewish population
because I don't even know what river to
what [__] City but I would is it the
river to the Mediterranean or is is it
the Euphrates involved no no no all
right eup is in Iraq right all right I
don't hold the map yeah so from from
from they're saying if you want from the
river to the Sea it means no Israel
genocide of the Jewish people is this
that couldn't be further from the truth
and just to exemplify how warped and
twisted this concept has become is that
the Anti-Defamation League which is
essentially a lobbying Force to protect
Israel prior to October 7th on their
website they talked about this phrase
and said that it was just a phrase
commonly chanted at like Pro Palestine
demonstrations after October 7th they
went and retroactively changed revised
their own articles saying it's a
genocidal incitement it is absurd it is
absurd it's just saying free us we are
under occupation we are under medieval
Siege free the people since when is
saying free give people freedom and
Liberation to genocidal and it's so
crazy it's like I I feel like I'm living
in like a alternate reality watching one
side actually commit genocide and
justifying it by saying well they
hypothetically would commit genocide
against us so that's why we need to do
this like it is so bizarre a lot of
people it's a lot of people and it
um it's crazy it's it's crazy it's crazy
and it's um what would what would an
appropriate response be when you have an
attack like that obviously Israel is not
going to do nothing so what's an
appropriate response obviously I think
the leveling of the buildings and you
know the displacement of I guess 70% of
pal Ians now right or something crazy 70
70% are internally displaced yeah 70% of
people are displaced from their homes
that's crazy um what is a what is a
response I mean I think any response
other than carpet bombing the entire
area would have been a better response
but again I can't even answer that Tim
because it really goes back to like how
did this happen because that's how I
look at like all US foreign policy 911 I
mean you could look at anything and be
like well why did this happen cuz I I
want know the roote of why violence
occurs why violence begets violence and
I want to get to that route and stop it
at the root and the root is occupation
and Siege you cannot do this to people
you you think that it's that do you
think that there are instances where
there the root causes
are um I'm not going to say they don't
matter per se but there are you know
times when an act is so egregious or uh
you know for example like when this
happened when Hamas did this the first
thing Israel's there's no way Israel's
going to sit down and go well you know
what is the root right I mean we we know
that we know that that they're not going
to do that so I'm trying to figure out
what would have been a
appropriate respon like there's no way
that's going to happen and they're going
to kidnap children and all this stuff
and then Israel is going to go okay what
do you guys want here's the borders here
you know so if you're going to try to
get rid of
Hamas um obviously carpet bombing is not
the right way to do it uh or it's an
incredibly brutal way to do it and it's
probably going to create new generations
of Hamas terrorists you know it's I I
know that it's tough and I just don't
know
what what their course of
action I obviously what they're doing
now is is Extreme and and I think
counterproductive um uh what would have
been the move do you think they have a
right to defend themselves when
something like that happens under
international law does Israel have the
right to defend itself if people are
coming like do they have the right to
defend themselves by going into Gaza and
carpa bom and Gaza absolutely not right
do they have the right to defend
themselves once Hamas is in these kabut
sure that's a different story because
when they take the hostages right so
they have taken a bunch of hostages and
so has Israel Israel has thousands of
political prison you look at the
prisoners that Israel that that they
were asked to release and it reveals the
barbarity of the situation 300 people
the vast majority are children the vast
majority have not been charged with
anything they just are languishing in
detention and like 30 of them have been
charged for I'm sorry have been held for
just throwing rocks I mean these people
are held for years under administrative
detention Israel is the only country in
the world that has military Courts for
kids that's crazy so what is the answer
that Israel should have done uh I I
can't answer that what I can answer is
that um I I think that you know when
we're talking about self-defense no one
talks about the right for self-defense
of the people that they're actually
occupying and everyone's obsessed with
Israel's right to have self-defense
against the people that they're
colonizing if we ended occupation ended
tomorrow what what does that look like
does it look like Palestinians living in
Israel with full voting rights what does
that look what does an ended OCC
occupation look like so you mentioned
apartheid and how that works and you
know it it is really Stark because aarte
is a institutional um system of
discrimination and segregation against
one racial group right and superiority
of Muslims live in uh Israel they sit on
the Supreme Court this is stuff that
Noah said is that not true so is it is
true and that's kind of all part of the
ruse just as the ruse is for the
Palestinian Authority to have a semi
part of a control of area a you know of
the West Bank Palestinian authorities in
control so then Israelis can be like oh
no no they're they control themselves
not talking about area B and C and how a
boss is just basically an appendage of
the Israeli State and everyone hates him
um Israelis are sorry Muslims and um
palest I'm sorry Palestinians who have
Israeli citizenship they're
tokenized and they have very minute
roles in Israeli society and right so a
couple sit on in the knesset and then
they can be like oh look Arabs have a
voice too they are routinely
discriminated against there are dozens
of laws within Israel proper that
discriminated against Palestinians
living there they can't unify with
family that they marry outside of Israel
they if they don't have slavish loyalty
to Israel they can be kicked out of
Jerusalem um they can't celebrate their
Palestinian Heritage uh there are so
many rules and I'm talking about Israeli
citizens Israeli citizens there are pog
BS against Israeli Palestinians in the
Muslim courts of East Jerusalem they
have to board up
their um businesses all the time because
people come through and try to firebomb
them and uh throw rocks at their windows
and chant death to Arabs to them this is
the reality there it is a ruse and and
it's false to say that they have full
rights and then when you look at the
apartheid nature of the West Bank it's
completely obvious that it's an
apartheid state I think the solution
that's up to Palestinians whether they
want two state or one state but I think
with the atomization of the West Bank
and how much settlement it realistically
it's up to the Israelis right because I
mean like the Palestinians don't really
have they don't have the right so it
seems like the Israelis would have to
get on board with a two State I don't
think at one state that seems like it
won't happen it seems like especially
with the nature of the Israeli
government today which is openly
fascistic it seems very tough would a
one state work or would it just be chaos
I think that it would work eventually I
think that again like there has to be
International observers and bodies and
there has to be a real like the whole
world has to help make this
infrastructurally sound and and make it
work and you have to remove the
settlements that are illegal you have to
right but Israel is also going to say
we're somewhat Progressive westernized
country you also have a lot of people in
Gaza that do not overlap with Israel
value-wise right so if you know if how
does that work in a one-state solution
one state solution I think that if you
have people in Goda that go we we we
we're not into women's rights we're not
into gay rights we're not into uh we're
into more of a Theocratic type of regime
and people in Israel that are like we're
not uh into that as much we're into
whatever we're into how do they all get
along and hang out and play soccer I
mean how the hell do Americans get along
it's barely hanging on by the seat of
our pants yes but for sure but we have a
we have laws that recognize you know we
we have a system of laws where people
can you know whatever they want to do
but it's like we're not we're not
constantly in in like California Texas
which fight all the time are not in a
constant state of terrorist Warfare
right I mean we [__] on each like people
[__] on the other one and they both are
kind of shoting each other all the time
yeah they're kind of but it's not like
it is with it like it's just weird to
see a I don't know if a one State's
going to work right it seems and I mean
maybe it would I don't know maybe a lot
of the beliefs that Palestinians have
are simply because they are under this
uh you know they have Hamas leading them
you know I don't know right it's like a
lot of the you know the the a lot of the
oppressive nature of uh Muslim countries
or Arab is a lot of it was backed by the
US right uh Iran for example is a
progressive country before the coup we
all know that right we're not stupid um
but right now you you know a lot of
those countries are autocracies right
and the people don't have rights and
things like that um so when Israel goes
hey we're this thing we're one thing and
the people over there don't believe in
any of that how does that all work it
just seems like it wouldn't work per se
you know I I don't see how they're all
going to live happily without a lot of
violence and
Chaos I I don't either at the beginning
I think that look we just have to look
at what is the right thing to do I think
that Israel is a fascist state right now
I mean they are going around and
arresting and throwing Israelis in jail
for just simply saying things on they
certainly are they're they're certainly
in a uh it's an incredibly right-wing
government they're on war footing and
they are you know doing what we did
probably right after 9/11 which is like
you know anyone that's dissenting we
were I don't know if we arresting them
but we were certainly they were
suffering you know uh you know
persecution socially and old you know
financially and all these other ways um
Israel is a rogue State at this point I
mean even the US wouldn't be able tried
to the man at all no Bush HW Bush did Oh
you mean back in the day he did he tried
and when you said gotten worse yes they
have because back in the day it did seem
like there was a motic come of
possibility for the two states because
especially before especially like the
whole 67 borders after that the
incremental taking over of the West Bank
and the atomization of the West Bank has
made it almost impossible for a second
state to exist unless those settlements
are removed that's why the settlements
got to go the settlements have to go
yeah there's 100,000 like nearly there
has to be uh they have to rebuild Gaza
there has to be uh I don't think Israel
can have a security role in Gaza that
seems crazy I think Arab countries are
going to have to as well as America
uh and probably also Israel have to kick
in for a a huge rebuilding of Gaza there
has to be um I mean there has to be some
type of you know understanding that
Israel and America should not have any
security role I mean that that that's
been suggested by netanyahu's government
that they'll have a permanent security
role in Gaza with us help that seems
insane mean insane it's crazy and what I
meant to say before is 700,000 settlers
are in the West Bank right now that are
legally squatting 700 ,000 they need to
be they need to go um but but the the US
won't even do what Israel's doing
because they are so worried about
tarnishing their credibility like
right it's crazy what Israel is doing I
have to stress that that again like
targeting all of
the factors of Civ this is the case
where they're targeting civilians and is
people in Israel are going to go that's
not true we're not it's collateral
damage but it does seem that there's so
many civilians dying that it's harder to
buy the collateral damage argu man when
so many civilians are dying well look at
this again like look at the rhetoric of
Israeli politicians they're not denying
that they are targeting civilians they
call Israeli defense minister said we're
going to completely tighten the siege
because they are human animals and we
need to act accordingly yeah and that's
crazy flatten Gaza flatten Gaza you look
at tons of knesset members dozens of
Israeli officials have said explicitly
they are subhuman we need to annihilate
Gaza if that's not targeting civilians
what the hell are we talking about here
no yeah that's crazy and here's why
they're doing it because they it's not
just uniquely evil right it's not just
indiscriminate bar it's not just like
inexplicable barbarism it is strategic
to Target all sectors of Civil Society
so you can terrorize the population this
is what happened during the knma during
NOA during 14 1948 is that you terrorize
enough of the population so that the
rest of them flee and that was when
700,000
Palestinians expelled were including I I
I saw you talked to Alana Hadid gig
hadid's sister and I think their family
yeah yeah every Palestinian that you
know around has a story and has a shared
history of being ethnically cleansed
from that region um and Mia Khalifa too
I just spoke to her and she's Lebanese
she grew up during Israeli occupation
and so they are targeting all of the
most important sectors of Civic Society
so all the Press offices you think Jews
have claim to that land you know for
example I have uh Jewish friends that
say we were there first I mean when I
talk
about
supposedly scientists have
found bone fragments that are Jewish
people like literally this is what is
put out they go we've been there for
thousands of years we were there from
the dawn of time we have a claim to that
land do they have a legitimate
claim is I mean that's the question
right because Palestinians were there so
they clearly have a claim and a lot of
people say that Jewish people were there
for 400 years 500 they were there for a
very long time do the Jewish people in
your estimation and again I mean to say
I've not looked into this is would be
the understatement of the year although
I've read I've read a little bit about
it but I'm not an expert on this um at
all you know other than to say that
like the there there's been a lot of
stuff put forward saying that Jewish
people have been there a long time and
that they have some claim to that land
and that they were kicked out of all of
these countries and they were ran all
over the world because of anti-Semitism
and this that and the other thing and
they wanted to state after the Holocaust
and then they were like it was natural
for us to return to this place that we
had been since the Biblical times is I
mean I don't believe in the Bible so I
would say religious fundamentalism
doesn't play into my analysis of like
geopol itics but I mean I this is the
claim this is the claim I mean it's a
ludicrous claim to to look at ancient
prophecy and say we have the right to to
ethnically cleanse indigenous people
does Israel have the right to exist on
top of another people's land and Exist
by ethnically cleansing an indigenous
population by violent bloody Conquest
day-to-day no right um but you mentioned
something that I just want to finish my
point because it's really important why
are they targeting all of these civilian
infrastructures in Gaza because they
want to make life impossible to return
Tim it's not just about it's not just
about like terrorizing the population to
flee it's to make it impossible to come
back because there's nothing left right
there is no there are no schools no
mosques no hospitals the hospitals to
actually have a war on Health Facilities
like that and targeting do and not just
like bombing hospitals not just bombing
hospitals they have a grid of where
everyone lives they have complete
surveillance over Gaza they go and
target with high precision
missiles that are massive and will level
like 10 [__] buildings that surround
these buildings they will Target doctors
and surgeons and the head of the
healthcare facilities and they they will
kill their entire families right that is
crazy they have killed 67 journalists
this is the deadliest Conflict for
journalists for like 50 years I mean it
is unbelievable that they are doing is
targeting journalists and killing their
entire families targeting them and that
is a fact just like Shen abule an
American citizen who worked for Al jazer
she was sniped by an Israeli sniper and
then they attacked her funeral
procession in the West Bank and there
was no accountability from the West at
all that's what they do they're a rogue
State and they need to be rained in and
the only reason they're doing it is
because they can get away with it Tim
because of the US backing them
uncritically and giving them a complete
green light to do whatever they want
when would that change do you think does
that is there because there are people
that are now looking at this going this
is crazy there are I think the vast
majority of Americans want ceasefire I
think that you know Americans support
Israel Americans support uh you know the
Israeli culture you know like the idea
of you know the Jewish culture and
understand that you know they face a
challenge in that region to a degree
because they are you know certainly
surrounded by people that do not like
them for various reasons um but I think
even Americans that are sympathetic to
that are going this is over the line and
this is not good for America to co-sign
this and support this without
constraints I this is a lot of people
you know yeah Jewish people friends of
mine you know are saying like this is a
not a good
situation um I remember after 9/11
America went on a project and it was a
project that was described by General
Wesley Clark uh In that clip where he
said seven countries in years seven
countries in five years and you
know it's uh it's destabilized the
entire region it's sent floods of people
all over Europe it's destabilized
political situations in Europe you see a
lot of um you know right-wing people
getting elected all over the world
you know because people are rightly you
know concerned about immigration and the
economy and and cultural differences and
things like that but a lot of that is
because we went into these places right
we went into Iraq we went into Libya you
know we have issues with in Syria um we
funded Saudi Arabia to do what amounts
to be a genocide in Yemen we're you know
we made a
so I I wonder if you know is is not
doing something similar right now where
there's going to be lots of unintended
consequences from this oh my God that's
the understatement of the century I mean
already the fight between Hezbollah and
Israel could erupt into a full-blown
Regional War it is terrifying what is
happening on the Lebanese border um and
again like Yemen you know the houthis
have commandeered a ship right um
they're they've sent warning shots
saying you have to stop the genocide
otherwise we're going to retaliate
Iran I mean this is really scary people
who are rightfully terrified about us
support of Ukraine right spiraling out
into a a World War III this is equally
if not more scary because of of how
rapid it's happening and how much the
the US seems to have no qualms
whatsoever well yeah there HW Bush
really tried to he said this is not good
for American foreign policy to not
recognize that there needs to be a
two-state solution look at osam Bin
Laden not to like not to justify
anything at all but you have just like a
lot of people have pointed out what are
these people talking about right when
you just paint people as cartoon evil
like Putin right like Assan it's usually
pretty clear what the rationale is I
don't I don't condone killing any
civilians I [__] killing civilians we
all on listen on this show we've
constantly been real a realist about
everything and said that you know listen
I obviously live in America so I have a
I have a desire to see uh America not
destroyed which you know if I lived in
China or somewhere else they don't have
that same desire right you know they
they have a desire to see China not
destroyed um that being said I
understand why encroaching on Russia uh
with you know potentially admitting
Ukraine into NATO and putting you know
potentially missiles there and
sponsoring a coup there in 2014 you know
I understand Putin where Russia's been
invaded several times worrying about the
territorial territorial Integrity of his
country would feel threatened and
rightfully so I also understand that if
you were a Palestinian and you were
living under this
occupation why would you do not
embrace the people that are trying to
get you out of it which is Hamas right
or I understand the pathology that
happens when you feel hopeless you
know that's you know it's they they hate
us for our freedoms Canard right which
is not something that I've ever bought
into that doesn't absolve that doesn't
mean I want to live in every country
that doesn't mean I think all cultures
are equal either you know I don't
believe all cultures are equal I don't
believe that uh my interests uh are you
know served by every culture uh or every
part of the world and I don't I don't
think forcing all these people to live
together is going to work I mean this is
something that's just my thing and it's
a lot of people across the world are are
you know responding to this idea that
everybody's going to live together
peacefully uh may not be the case I
don't know but subjugating people is a
Bad Thing subjugating people is a bad
thing cuz not only it's a moral problem
but it's a political issue because of
blowback yeah what you just said yeah it
does come back to you you know yeah we
don't have to be we don't have to
hi love each other and love each other I
don't have an interest in
telling Yemen how to live I don't have
an interest as an American telling the
yemenis how to behave I don't that's not
in my interest right I was not in my
interest telling Iraq how to behave or
or that that uh that Afghanistan
Warlords have to live like people in
Vermont I have no interest in that I
certainly don't have an interest in it
at gunpoint it doesn't seem to be
effective right um uh so that really
becomes the issue is that you have you
have a situation where people are really
hopeless and they're
embracing uh these uh pathologies
because of this situation and we need to
figure out a way to not make it worse
and by giving Israel unending streams of
money and then I think Biden just said
we're gonna take the weap what did he
say more Hellfire missiles hands of
Israel I mean I think that what you just
said was great and I totally agree with
it and I think that we don't have to be
intellectual cowards we can be super
honest and Frank about why things are
happening right and analyze the context
behind why things are happening instead
of pretending like Putin is some
aberration some cartoon evil villain who
just acts out of pure cruelty pure
malice pure malice you just can't Guy
this is the guy that after 911 called us
and said really sorry has never launched
a war on Western interests once has
never Putin's never done anything right
instead of instead of being honest they
ban Russian media they they just try to
sanitize our reality Chris Hedges the
big threat and me my show don't forget
about me man I mean it's CRA to purge
history when I was I know I I criticize
Russ on my show I mean it's just so
crazy to just sanitize our reality and
say you're not you can't handle the
truth Tim we just have to tell you what
to believe just just listen to us you
can't actually hear what Putin's saying
you can't analyze the situation for
yourself so that's when I look at
anything that's being painted as this
and I apply it to groups like Hamas
right and I want to learn what is Hamas
and why are they doing what they do I
don't think that you can paint everyone
in Gaza suffering at the hands of Israel
as people who are aspired to join Hamas
but I will say that the people in Hamas
certainly have suffered at the hands of
Israel I'm sure the vast majority have
lost their paramilitary group it's a
paramilitary group um it's sure it's a
terrorist group but again what are they
going to do outside of terrorism you
know this is what happens right this is
unfortunately uh you know and it's not
doesn't condone it it doesn't excuse it
it doesn't justify what it says is
contextually when people feel like they
have zero hope and they've seen their
family and friends murdered they Embrace
these pathologist this isn't new right
it doesn't mean that all terrorism comes
from that and it doesn't mean that all
malice or evil in the world comes from
that either there are people that do bad
things for the sake of doing bad things
there are people that want control over
other people for the sake of it there
are people that I'm sure want to
ethnically cleanse Israel uh IM material
of what Israel does I'm I'm sure that
those people do exist I know they exist
and I've I've heard them but in this
particular situation it does feel like
there has to be a way
to give Palestinians autonomy and rights
and
prevent decades more of this and cycles
of violence and I don't think Hamas is a
terrorist group yeah and is that well
they engage in terrorism right I mean
it's a terrorist thing does that mean
it's such an arbitrary term I want to be
clear about what we're talking about
well you could say that Israel is
engaging in it too anybody who's
engaging in the type of stuff that we're
doing but I I think when you go to music
fful indiscriminately killing people
that seems to be terrorism right if you
kidnap children that seems to be
terrorism right I mean it doesn't now
you might say they don't have uh the
military to engage like but when you're
hitting soft civilian targets as
Israel's done so I'm not absolving them
to me that's kind of the definition of
terrorism it's like soft civilian now
that that means like there's a lot of
armies that you could say but I wouldn't
say Hamas is not a terrorist group
because their
aims you know seem to be to inflict
Terror on the Israeli population and the
same way that Israel in the way that is
behaving now seems to inflict Terror on
so I I don't I don't want to absolve one
group and say that the other group
because they both seem to want to do the
same thing you know I mean Israel is
doing it with a military but that
doesn't mean that it's not terrorism
right and I mean that might mean that
all war is Terrorism but I wouldn't want
to solve Hamas I don't know what Hamas
wants for Gaza that's part of the hard
thing right I don't know what Hamas I
know that they've taken a lot of money
from Qatar I don't know what they've
done with it and I don't know if they
have the best interest of people in Gaza
at heart I don't know that that I know
that they want uh the Israeli occupation
to end but I don't know enough about
them to know what exactly are they good
at governing Gaza are they a legitimate
because it seems like they're not good
at
that well it's hard to govern a
population that's under blockade don't
allow clean water I have no idea I mean
that's a thing is you look at the world
and you look at places like Egypt and
and other places in the Middle East and
it's a lot of repression and it's like
what would this region look like without
us interference I don't know there's a
ton of oil wealth there's a ton of money
t oil wealth that that strikes at the
heart of why it's such an important
Colonial Outpost for the US I don't know
if you just saw this this clip from RFK
Junior actually just explicitly laying
bear the utility of Israel for the US
Empire I've never actually seen someone
seen but I think that's an open seat
people know that know it people know it
yeah for sure but but so I think that
like also debunks the whole like why do
you care about Israel so much it's like
I it's it's the US yeah Outpost in the
is any of that repression also religious
is any of that religious where you go
this is something that is just
inherently based in religion but what
has allowed the religious rep repression
to flourish it's it's stemming and
subjugating populations for sure and a
lot of policy Pockets where religious
fundamentalism has has but then you have
countries like Saudi Arabia that are
incredibly wealthy and Incredibly
powerful and who's the and who is
preventing any sort of sanctions or
International laws Saud Arabia NBS is
kind of opening that Society up now
right right little by little I don't
think so seems to that's a PR campign
well they've they've certainly made a
lot of uh advancements I mean you know
whether it's enough advancements
allowing women to drive finally in some
and I disagree with that but they're
doing that and I'm not even huge on them
voting I say go to the arys tour I don't
I don't you know my whole thing with
women is keep your [__] away from me
and don't vote but and I but I love them
in every other capacity but my my whole
thing is I tried you know what no but I
I I'm saying that there is is there does
seem to be like whether it's
fundamentalist Christianity or
fundamentalist Islam or fundamentalist
Judaism fundamentalist religion is a
problem too that removed from politics
removed from the concerns there does
seem to be in all cultures uh a a need
to enslave People based on religion that
is like if if we got rid of all us
Empire things would none of that exist
because it existed before the US Empire
this idea that religion would just
dictate and there would be certain
people that would like you know rise to
the top of societies by promise and we
see it in America right we see it right
now with Christians going like you know
follow me I represent God and I'm making
the laws based on God so I mean that's
been around forever it's pre us pre a
lot of that so I there is some of that I
I think that America's made a lot of
mistakes we've done a lot of wrong
things but like I don't think it's all
there is this idea that every evil in
the world comes from
colonialism Andor white people which I
don't know I don't subscribe to that I
know that you're you have friends that
do and there's nothing wrong with that
there's nothing wrong with that but to
defend Whitey for a
minute prior to whitey and colonialism
there was a lot of brown on Brown
colonialism there was a lot of brown on
Brown slavery and there was a lot of
religious fundamentalism going on all
over the place we didn't invent slavery
and we certainly didn't invent
colonialism look my my answer to that is
I can only do what I can do as an
American citizen we're trying to pitch
you to the white supremacist we're
trying to get you on no you know what
I'm saying I I totally I totally hear
you and I can't do anything about
religious fundament a talks about racist
vegetables I'm saying it doesn't help
just get everyone healthy what I what I
can do is try to exert some sort of
pressure on my government that's right
and that's what we respect the hell out
of you for doing so much problems around
the world the reason that I respect you
is because so many people sit on Twitter
you go to the West
Bank so many people sit there and throw
you know their takes out you go and make
a documentary you talk to people I mean
whether people agree with you or not um
there are very few people I think Glenn
Greenwald is one of them I think you're
one of them um I I think there's very
few others that are out
there truly taking risks for the stuff
you write and the stuff you make truly
I'm genuinely curious and I really want
to know what's going on for sure you
know especially because of how much the
media lies it's like I want to go and
talk to the people who we're talking
about yes a
th% um are you allowed in Israel by the
way that's just curious good question I
I don't really want to buy a flight I
don't want to buy a flight and then just
get there and then be like get the [__]
out of here I mean if I I do want to
what if we dress up like
rabbis what if me and Abby Martin try to
get into Israel dress up like
rabbis CAA drops Tim Dylan after Abby
Martin Rabbi stunt in Tel I can see it
now I can see it now jog will call me
he's like come on it was wild it was
wild with you and ab your done um
where can people watch your documentary
where can they support your work where
can they read your stuff we know RT they
got rid of it got rid of it but where
because tons of people were like you
know when I had Noah on they were like
you don't have a and I was like I'm
gonna have someone on that is going to
present another side to it a th% you are
the best person of all the people that I
think are out there and there's a lot of
smart people but I haven't seen anyone
do work on this issue even when no one
was caring about it like you were there
boots on the ground interviewing people
so if people want to watch Gaza fights
for Freedom or they want to read what
you do support the Empire files where do
they go go to YouTube okay all it's
still up so the documentaries for free
up on YouTube right now on the Empire
files Channel we also have a whole
playlist reporting from Palestine tons
of videos from the occupied West Bank um
you can go to Gaza fights forf
freedom.com to watch the documentary in
tons of other languages for free and I
do have to say that the lead organizer
of the great March of return my good
friend Ahmed Arta who I'm in contact
with his uh 10-year-old son was murdered
and they targeted his home and and
murdered um his five members of his
family and he's in the hospital with
second degree burns he is like the
Palestinian Gandhi that we keep being
told needs to do something peacefully so
this is what's happening all the people
who worked on the film are suffering to
the lead videographer of the film both
of his brothers were murdered his home
is completely uh reduced to Rubble it is
terrifying and devastating and if you
cherish the sanctity of human life which
you and I do yeah please call for a
ceasefire because our Representatives
need to be pressured they need to be
called that's the most urgent pressing
demand Tim and Republicans and Democrats
overwhelmingly support this because how
much more Carnage and dead children can
we take to find our basic Humanity yeah
and I know you're a mother and you know
and even as someone who doesn't have
kids to see the the Carnage and the
devastation I also think we got to get
uh you know some type of way out of this
so that this isn't a generational issue
you know whether that's a two-state
solution I also think we got to get
hostages released we got to get all of
that stuff Hamas has got to release
hostages we gotta um right now the
hostages that remain are the only
leverage to not destroy the rest of Gaza
and after that the hostages are released
Netanyahu said that he's returned to
flatten the rest of God well this is
when America we really have to we it's
up to us it is it really is up to us is
Trump crazy qu let's throw out a crazy
question just before Abby Martin leaves
let's throw out a crazy crazy crazy wild
question now I keep in mind I know you
have to go home after you say this
please Trump in office now better or
worse it's uh very interesting here
here's what I think would happen I think
he might not be worse I think Trump
would be doing exactly what Biden is
doing but without the
humanitarian cover that TR might
actually I don't know if Trump would
be I think he might engage Israel more
than Biden I think so I don't know I
don't have evidence he did give him he
did try to move the embassy to Jerusalem
that's that was a big horrible he did
some wacky stuff but here's what I think
would be happening liberals would be
more
mad right interesting
will be more mad right now I think do
you think Trump wins again magic mind
contains a magical combination of 12
active ingredients scientifically
designed to improve energy Focus mood
while decreasing stress all things that
combined improve your productivity I'm
going to try it right
now it's actually amazing it tastes good
and I feel more productive already you
don't need coffee or tea anymore people
used to have coffee or tea every day hey
now they're doing this this is what
Young tech people are doing and this is
those are the people that are I mean
wouldn't you right they're getting you
know what I mean yeah those are the
people people see them and go what are
they you know and we're all behind the
eightball we don't know what's going
on but magic mind because I'm I'm not
stressed when I have this I'm but I
still want to be productive but not in a
stressful way which is
wild
many people drink it on an empty stomach
without a
problem some people might have an issue
but a lot of people are fine maybe A
light meal 30 minutes before or after
drinking magic mine if you discover that
it's an issue for you it's not an issue
for me I drink it on an empty
stomach it's it's like this is the new
thing that everybody's doing everybody's
micro doing mushrooms right yeah
everybody's you know because people now
are going how do we you know all those
things like those
futuristic things where food would just
be like a blue
mush that's what you know that's what
this
is but it's not blue it's green and it's
it has all the things you need in it
that's the thing food's not going to be
like a big thing where you sit there
with like a bunch of
plates it's going to be a thing where
you just take a shot yes I think this
was the red line for Biden I I've seen
so many polls not just with genen z and
Millennials which really helped secure
the midterms I think because of roie
Wade those people are the ones on the
front lines all across the country
demanding a ceasefire and on top of that
Arab and Muslim and Palestinian voters
Tim how could you support a man who de
facto committed genocide because this
wouldn't be happening without the US
weaponry and support and financial
backing this is on Biden's hands and if
I mean if I were a Palestinian or I mean
I'm I'm not going to [__] vote for
Biden right but like how could I know a
lot of people on the left could they
that are not thrilled with Biden for a
myriad of reasons but this being one oh
this is this is I mean there's no
turning back from this this is hisy I
think Trump I gotta be honest with you
might be doing a better job of handling
this now I don't I don't know I cannot
base that on much but well Trump is out
there saying to be fair Trump's out
there saying let's Deport all Hamas
sympathizers I don't know what the [__]
that means I don't know if it just means
conflating Pro Palestine demonstrators
with Hamas sympath I don't know what who
the hell know I do know there's a lot
there's a lot of things being said you
know um but I I do feel like Biden just
seems
cognitively he's weaken at Bernie he's a
Walking Corpse this guy with forget the
political reality the Biden seems so out
of it I don't know what he could be on
the out there talking about beheaded
babies just yesterday it's like what in
the Holy hell are you talking about man
like oh my God yeah um it's I just want
a diplomatic solution I want I I just
want it to end I want the violence in
Carnage to end I want the occupation to
end no one's talking about expelling
Israelis from the land when we talk
about a one-state solution or a
two-state solution Israeli Jews will
have a very important place in whatever
the
solution with abandoned settlements yes
um we it gets rolled back no more
expansionism stop bombing Syria stop
bombing Lebanon stop doing all this
stuff just cut it out because it's the
holidays we're all trying to enjoy the
holiday it's annoying to
me um you know what I mean we've got
other problems like the screen actor's
guild but no I mean like the strike you
know that's why I couldn't do the voice
over for the Hamas leader
I can't believe this hospital we got all
these ambulances here I can't believe it
happened how did it happen um thank you
for flying out thank you for coming out
I appreciate it um you know like I said
this is uh it's a comedy show that we
usually do I do a single person show
where I just yell for an hour um but we
do have people on occasionally that we
respect and we think they're they're
worth listening to um and um you have
really done a ton of research and you
you know there are people that don't
agree with you obviously um but no one
can say that you're not immersed in this
in a deep way this is like the issue
that I've always you know looked at the
stuff you've done and I'm like you're
out there working on it so anyone that
wants to know more about it whichever
side you're on including people that
don't agree with anything you've said
you know go watch the thing and you know
go because I know a lot of Israeli
people that go that are Americans that
go that are Jewish that are not Israeli
that go yeah they go I went on like
Birthright they go it does seem crazy
what's going on over there and they go I
don't really even know that much about
it they I don't know it just seems nuts
you know and then there are people that
are very you know well I mean that's
goaz ofits for Freedom really tells you
and it's it's actually changed the minds
of a lot of Israeli Jews too who didn't
know because are indoctrinated from
birth and when you go on Birthright you
don't even know about the occupied West
Bank you don't go into it and so I've
had people say this changed my mind
because it shows you what happens when
Palestinians peacefully resist and what
the actual context in state of Gaza is
um check it out Gaza fights freedom.com
you can check out Empire files we're on
all platforms we do a hell of a lot of
other work too Tim we're working on a
documentary right now about the US
military being the world's largest
polluter earth's greatest enemy I don't
believe it I refuse I refuse to believe
that they are not are you telling me the
US military is dumping things in areas
they shouldn't I I I won't hear it I
won't hear that heresy um Abby Martin
thank you I appreciate thank you so much
appreciate it I know your comedy show
this was very brave to do because people
get actually cancelled for doing this so
well I appreciate you the good news is
I'm already really
rich all right thank you Abby appreciate
it Tim appreciate you